How do you plan to pitch your business?
If you're not sure,
you'll have a hard time getting
investors excited about your message.
That's why you need a pitch deck and
a script of what you plan to say
when presenting your product.
So what is a pitch deck and
how do you make one?
A pitch deck is the first communication
tool to help you raise money
with a potential investor.
We'll be building that
throughout this lesson.
To pitch your business effectively,
we'll focus on three main parts,
the introduction, the details,
and the closing statement.
Each of these parts have a few pieces
inside of them that you'll be writing
throughout this lesson.
Let's have a closer
look at each of them.
First, before even starting,
you'll gather all the materials
you've built for your business.
You'll be summarizing these
throughout your pitch.
Then, to introduce your startup,
you'll need a hook,
a description of the problem you solve,
and your solution to this problem.
Next, you'll provide a few
details about your startup.
We'll focus on the market size,
product, user validation,
monetization strategy, competitive
analysis, and marketing plan.
This is a lot to cover, so
you'll need to be brief and
focus on the most relevant
aspects of your business.
After all this,
you need to close strong.
You'll introduce your team,
the next steps you plan to take and
finally wrap up everything to leave
investors with something to remember.
Throughout this lesson, we'll focus on
writing each of these pieces to help
you prepare your pitch deck.
>From there, you'll be ready to
describe your business in a concise,
engaging story for investors.
So let's get started
building your pitch deck.